the Joe Rogan experience yeah I listen
to a chunk of that ul and Joey Diaz yeah
which by the way was amazing the way you
guys communicated that was like it's
pretty cooling but the yeah the the
Pyramid of athletics yeah your everyday
and you're living there it just made me
think about my own life which you know
my parents worked really hard to like
make me comfortable and here's your TV
and you go to school and you come home
from school and how that's the goal and
like suburban life is suggest be comfy
comfortable we don't realize it but this
is all because people before us weren't
we're just only living in the
environment where people are supposed to
be comfortable but you know just two
generations back everyone's an immigrant
and everyone's really concerned about
starving so I have to do go back to the
1920s everyone's worried about [ __ ]
dying the way the millions of people
died like even during World War two
millions of people died by starvation
yes that was a real concern I remember
you saying to him you're like yeah it
produced it produces really good not
lates
it might not be like the nicest
situation but there's no way you get
really nice situations that produce the
world's best combat sports athletes just
doesn't happen you have to be strong as
[ __ ] mentally physically you have to
have experienced adversity on a level
that most people can never comprehend so
that when the [ __ ] hits the fan that you
could look at the other guy on the other
side of the cage like uol Romero does
and goes I'm gonna go [ __ ] you up I've
been through everything already even
then the other guy's the same way so you
though it doesn't even work yeah I don't
really relate to that like trying to
[ __ ] up the dude and going through so
much adversity am i well I want my point
of view is like I'm gonna do my chores
and I'm so comfortable right now now I'm
going to deliberately make myself
uncomfortable in order to do what I know
is good for me and that I enjoy doing
and that I want to have success in and
that takes me to another place in my
life but it's you know I do it in a very
small way you know I do but it's still
really honestly the same thing what Yael
is doing and what you're doing is the
same thing
doing something very difficult that you
it's you struggle to do it it's hard you
push yourself miss recognize you want to
do it yes and in through doing it you
get a little bit better at everything
did he talk about I only watched the
first chunk of it did he talk about his
desire to do that or not you know like
yeah yeah he does and how does that how
does that match with kind of being put
in that system I think you asked that
early on to was like how do they choose
how do you choose you just want someone
who's what if you're the natural ability
but you don't want to do it well then
you won't perform and if you don't
perform you get knocked out of the cyst
so there is the desire there has to be
to be as good as he is there has to be
desire to compete he wanted to be a
boxer initially said but his father was
a boxer I think his brother is a world
champion boxer as well he's just a
genetic for wreak like there's genetics
in Cuba and he was explaining it to me
- he's during the podcast he was like
anybody that thinks that everyone's on
steroids just go to Cuba where
everybody's so poor and look at the
regular people just the regular people
forget about the athletes he said I'll
take you to Cuba for two weeks and
you'll come back you like I get it I get
it
there's just really it was a slave
colony they had a hard life I mean it's
it's that's there Africans that speak
Spanish and they live on an island
that's off the coast of Florida I mean
it's a crazy spot the whole thing's
crazy it was run by a dictator forever
and they had some of the best athletes
in the world in boxing in judo in
wrestling just world-class athletes that
had mental toughness the likes of I mean
it's hard for the average person to even
comprehend what those people are capable
of and a lot of it is because of that
really brutal system that you all talked
about on the podcast amazing stuff yeah
you know just just imagining that this
guy went through that you know it's
fascinating cuz yeah that's not what I
want to do it's not what you want to do
but you just think like that there's a
person out there that can do that and
look what happens on the other end you
get that guy like oh Jesus he was just
been in the room with him it's just he's
like a [ __ ] superhero yeah that's
like Jesus that that is the product of
genetics ruthless training ruthless
environment
you know one of the most complex and
sophisticated sports training systems in
the world with boxing and with wrestling
and with judo I mean they're just
phenomenal over their school is really
inspiring in a different way for someone
like me like I don't relate necessarily
to what he does is like foreign and
amazing but through my own life it's
like oh I can be not comfortable and
like that's why it seems like a
contradiction but it's not like that's
what we're supposed to be doing
[Applause]